AND WE JUST BOUGHT
OUR FIRST HOME.
SO WE WENT TO SCREWS.
- HOW CAN I HELP YOU?
- SWEETHEART, WHAT IS IT
THAT WE WERE LOOKING FOR AGAIN?
- I DON'T REMEMBER.
- TED AND GWEN SAID THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR LIGHT BULBS,
BUT I COULD TELL BY
THE VACANT LOOK IN THEIR EYES
THAT THEY WANTED
SOMETHING MORE.
ARE YOU GUYS LOOKING
TO BUILD A SECRET ROOM?
- YES.
- NO.
both: YES.
[laughter]
- GREAT. FOLLOW ME.
- JOE WAS AMAZING.
JUST SO HELPFUL.
SEE, HE HELPED US BUILD
A SECRET ROOM
THAT WE COULD REALLY
GROW WITH.
I ALWAYS IMAGINED HAVING,
LIKE, A LOT OF CAPTIVES.
- WHEREAS I HAD ONLY EVER
ENVISIONED JUST ONE CAPTIVE.
- [chuckles]
WELL, I COME FROM A BIG FAMILY.
- THEY WERE ALL MOLESTED.
- HEY...
WE MOLESTED EACH OTHER.
- OH--
- I WAS MOLESTED
AS A CHILD TOO,
SO I KNEW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WERE GOING AFTER.
- IT'S SOUNDPROOF?
- UH-HUH.
THERE'S ALSO A HANDLE
ON IT.
- JOE WAS AMAZING ABOUT
ALL THE FINE DETAILS
AND PERSONAL TOUCHES
THAT WE NEVER WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT OF ON OUR OWN.
- YEAH, I MEAN, LIKE,
DIRTY BLANKETS
TO MAKE THE PLACE LOOK SICK.
- MM-HMM.
OR A DOOR THAT LEADS
TO NOWHERE.
- ALL AT SCREWS'
EVERYDAY LOW PRICES.
- ONE OF OUR FAVORITE THINGS
ABOUT JOE WAS THAT
HIS ETHNICITY
WAS NICE AND AMBIGUOUS.
- LIKE YOU COULD
CUT HIM UP AND EAT HIM,
AND YOU WOULDN'T KNOW
WHERE THE ORIGINS
OF THAT MEAT WAS FROM.
- BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
YEAH, EXOTIC.
- MM-HMM.
- IN A REALLY COOL WAY.
- YEAH.
- I'M FROM THE PACIFIC ISLANDS.
ALL ALONG THIS BACK PART HERE--
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
I DIDN'T PUT ENOUGH VENTILATION
IN HERE.
- SHUT YOUR PIG MOUTH!
- HEY. COME ON.
LET ME OUT OF HERE.